Nightwing Dick Grayson is Batman's
protege who became a superhero in his
own right and a particularly awesome one
at that far from being just a carbon
copy of Bruce Wayne
he has many of the same skills but on
top of that he's also a world-class
Acrobat he's incredibly gymnastic agile
fast he can jump high and he can parkour
across rooftops and it's the only man
alive in the DC Universe who's ever been
able to pull off the quadruple
somersault
so whereas Batman is portrayed as a
brick wall Nightwing is agile he's fast
he's acrobatic gymnastic and this is
fantastic inspiration for any of us who
want to become more agile ourselves if
we want to learn parkour and tricks and
flips or if we just want to increase our
own functional strength our mobility and
up a prior ception so that we can pull
off cool moves and build really
practical usable strength then I try to
do some flips and ya didn't go so well I
used to be able to do flips and stuff
but I'd definitely gotten worse and
that's because so many different aspects
of your health and performance
influenced your ability to pull off
these kinds of moves
in order to do a backflip you'd be
surprised at how much involvement there
is in your core for instance after all
you're bringing your knees up to your
stomach lots of other moves involve a
lot of torque
likewise flexibility jump height in
order to get enough air all these things
play a role and if you're lacking in any
of those areas you're not going to be
able to pull off these cool moves after
a day of trying backflips
your abs hurt so in this series of
videos I'm gonna look at how you can
build the kind of strength the kind of
flexibility that you'd need in order to
be able to perform those moons these
aren't gonna be tutorials it's just
gonna be talking about the kind of
strength and fitness you need for
parkour for tricking for gymnastics
because this is their massive topic I
want you to split it up into different
parts this is part one where I'm gonna
be talking about legs we're gonna create
a leg day by the end of this video we'll
be sharing a routine for training your
legs so you can jump higher perform
parkour all those cool things and in
future videos we're gonna look at a core
day for generating that talk we're going
to look at a push-pull day for upper
body gymnastic strength basically once
the series is over we'll have a full
workout and an explanation of why all
this stuff works and why you should be
doing it so if you wanna be able to jump
higher there are two things you need to
do two really simple things one is squat
and one is get lighter getting lighter
unfortunately does make sense if you
want to become more gymnastic if you
want to do more calisthenics yes you can
flip if you're big and bulky there are
certainly lots of people who can do that
like you Jimmy foo however if you become
lighter it's going to become a lot
easier I've been losing weight lately
using intermittent fasting and just
doing a little bit more cardio type
stuff and obviously this is something
you should focus on if you want to move
a little bit more like Nightwing as for
the squatting squatting uses many of the
same muscles as jumping and and most of
people have really high vertical jumps
for posting those things on Instagram
they got there by squatting heavy more
specifically though you want to be
squatting at 90 percent of your one rep
maximum by doing this you'll recruit
fast twitch muscle fiber any lower and
you'll be relying more on your slow
twitch muscle fiber and you won't build
quite as much explosiveness
unfortunately training really heavy
squats isn't that easy I find it really
hard to film when I'm doing it the squat
rack is always really busy and people
don't really like it when I film them
but luckily the leg press will serve as
a next best thing if you don't have a
spotter around you won't be using as
many stabilizing muscles but the
can accept somewhat similar and likewise
you can also just use squat jumps squat
jumps won't train your max strength in
quite the same way or your endurance
however you will be recruiting
fast-twitch muscle fiber because you're
still generating maximum force your body
doesn't really know the difference
between heavy weight and acceleration so
squat jumps going as high as you can and
practicing those box jumps will help to
develop more fast twitch muscle fiber in
your legs and when you're jumping don't
forget to monitor your progress maybe
make a mark on the wall see if you can
keep getting higher this is a really fun
way to Train this really explosive and
when you use it in conjunction with
squats it can make for some really
powerful and painful drop sets but
anyways squats won't use all of the
muscles you use in jumping for instance
it doesn't really use the curves in a
big way you're not actually launching up
in the air so another exercise you might
want to use to supplement is the calf
jump I've talked about this before it's
one of my favorites basically you keep
your legs straight and you jump up in
the air only by moving your feet so
you're pushing off your toes to jump in
the air without bending your legs or
using the other joints normally a
vertical jump is a three joint movement
we're just focusing on the one here in
order to add them together
likewise anything that trains your
posterior chain is going to be useful so
kettlebell swings deadlifts anything
like that
Nightwing has been seen training both of
the calisthenics and with weights so you
should use a combination of both as well
but whilst you're at it make sure you
actually are training that posterior
chain and that you're not too quad
dominant you see athletes can be
glutenin tour
quad dominant unfortunately because most
of us spends so much time sitting we
have very tight hips this makes us more
quad dominant therefore we're not using
our glutes quite as much when jumping
when running when performing all these
cool moves that are required for parkour
and martial arts and thus we're losing
out on what is the biggest muscle in the
body likewise if you do a whole bunch of
weighted lunges you'll find that you
feel the burn in the quads and not the
glutes because they haven't been doing
their job so how do we become more glute
dominant to become more explosive and
agile one option is just to try and
increase your mind muscle connection
make sure you really tensing the glutes
through the movement you can even
contract them in your spare time of the
part of your incidental training which I
talked about in my recent video
likewise try using specific glute
exercises things like weighted step ups
or perhaps barbell glute bridges
likewise go a bit lighter with your
squats to begin with because if you're
going too heavy you'll be forced to
cheat and that might mean using your
quads a little bit more we can also look
at Chong G's hyper arch theory he
reckons that using your feet in the
correct way has a big difference in
engaging either your quads more or your
glutes more he talks about using the
hyper arch position and hyper arch
squats basically this means keeping your
abs Jub next time when is a phone too
slippy basically this means keeping your
abs and your glutes tight and more
importantly keeping your feet too rigid
you can use hyper arch hops which means
bouncing on the balls of your feet
whilst keeping those arches engaged or
you can use his hyper arch squats which
means focusing on the feet keeping them
rigid while sturdy squats I'll be
talking about this more on future or you
can head over to his website I'll leave
the link in the description for a bit
more information it's an interesting
topic but I haven't looked into it
enough to know whether it's really worth
investing in likewise using foam rolling
and myofascial release can also help in
this area check out my video on fashio
for more on that but it's not all just
about being able to produce force
through your muscles there's more to
jumping high and being more agile than
that if you want to leap over bad guys
you also need to be flexible and you
need to have that springiness for
example one way to jump higher is to
stretch your tibialis anterior that's
the muscle on the front of your shin
this muscle is responsible for
dorsiflexion that basically means
lifting your foot upwards and because it
does that that means it also creates
resistance when you try and push your
foot to downwards the less flexible it
is more stiff it is the more resistance
you're faced when you try and push your
feet push your toes through the ground
whether you're jumping high or
delivering a kick or doing a wall run so
stretch that by stretching your foot
behind your back and you might find this
a little bit easier to jump higher of
course this is a very minor difference
but if you're really trying to maximize
your agility in your power and your
explosiveness that's a really
interesting thing to consider right
thing help its return even more energy
by using shock training shock training
means that we're absorbing a big impact
the most obvious example being depth
jumps that's where you're jumping off a
height and immediately launching
straight back into the air this does
several things that helps us to mimic
the movement of a jump and to create
more power absorbing impact in this way
as obviously a skill in itself if you're
nightwing you want to drop silently into
an alleyway
a rooftop but at the same time it stores
energy in our fashio in our tendons we
can then use to jump straight back up
one study found that volleyball players
using a depth to jump program were able
to increase their jump height by an
impressive 14% so this really does work
at the same time it allows us to use our
eccentric strength which is our ability
to slow down the elongation of the
muscle and that lets us use the myotatic
response this means that when the muscle
lengthens the body wants to shorten it
again as quickly as possible this reflex
can then be used to give us more power
and jumping but we can train it like
anything else so if you want to jump
higher make sure you're including depth
jumps and if you want more explosiveness
in general make sure you include things
where you're dropping down and launching
back up many plyometric exercises will
allow you to do this of course you're
seizing really high tuck jumps or jump
squats will also do something similar
for you finally if we want to increase
the agility on our legs if you want to
jump higher and become more explosive we
need to focus on our technique while it
actually made a fantastic documentary
talking about how to increase your jump
height for those amazing Instagram box
jump one of the key tips there was to
focus on dropping down into the squat
before launching straight back up in the
air even if you're not doing a depth
jump there's always an elongating of the
muscle there's always that storing of
energy you don't drop down too far but
if you drop down just far enough that's
going to allow you to return that energy
plus it lets you travel further before
you leave the ground thereby allowing
you to exert more force over time that's
where that eccentric strength comes in
the myotatic response and the low
hysteresis of our Achilles tendons don't
go too far or you'll make it harder for
yourself but don't go too shallow or you
won't have enough time to accelerate
through that movement if you want to
involve the feet more actually
maintaining a slight dorsiflexion of the
foots at the toes points slightly up can
likewise help to move your foot further
into the plantar flexion so you're going
from there to there instead of just from
here to there and thereby helping to
jump higher as well swinging the arms is
really important to get extra momentum
and leaning slightly forwards can help
as well it allows you to move your body
more upright as you go thereby creating
even more momentum when it comes to
dorsiflexion in its relationship with
jump height as well as agility and
precision and parkour things are
actually a little bit complicated that's
because you want to lower the hysteresis
reduce the pliability of your Achilles
tendon
in order to return more energy the
thicker and the tougher is the more
energy it will turn when it hits the
ground because it's basically like a
tighter piece of elastic at the same
time though if you don't have enough
flexibility in your Achilles heel then
this means you can't raise your toes as
much when you push down on the ground
the result is that you tend to lean your
body forward slightly more seeing as
we've already discussed that leaning
your body slightly forwards can help you
to jump higher this isn't the bad thing
in terms of jump height however it could
be a bad thing in terms of precision and
accuracy if you're trying to do
precision jumps as part of parkour maybe
leaping onto a small bollard and you
find yourself of them falling off it
might because you don't realize your
torso isn't entirely straight thereby
throwing your balance off the same thing
goes with performing pistol squats
therefore you want to increase your
ankle range of motion to an extent but
without making your Ackley's tendon
overly flexible my advice on this then
is not to stretch the Achilles tendon
specifically by pulling your toes up
towards you but rather to rely on things
like Hindu squats we were just moving
the ankle naturally through that range
of motion but actually the thing to
remember is that if we're trying to
train more like Nightwing or generally
to become more functional then most of
the time we're going to be launching off
of one foot and not two so that's really
what you want to develop so we also need
to integrate one-legged exercises into
our movements I did a whole video on
single leg strength this requires a
slightly different kind of stability you
need to engage your core and so it is
worth training separately at the same
time the bilateral deficit tells us that
we can produce more than half the power
we can with both legs with a single leg
so again there's a slightly different
process it's worth training separately
use pistol squats to use pistol squat
jumps use weighted step ups anything
we're using one leg at a time will help
you develop the technique and the power
for those single leg jumps at the same
time now though as well as using our
arms and our upper body to gain momentum
we can also use the spare legs we want
to swing that up hard as well we need to
think about our running speed because
the faster you run the higher and
further you'll be able to jump we need
to think about our ma V which is our
maximum approach velocity this is
something that you'll gain with practice
with all these things whilst all these
tips can hopefully help you to improve
your technique something to think about
I would say don't overthink it and keep
your eye on where you want to be and
what you want to go over and let your
body do the rest
often we're going to find ourselves
launching off of our dominant foot but
you want to make sure you train both
legs so that
necessary you can launch off of your
non-dominant leg as well this also means
that in order to increase her ability to
jump high off one leg in order to jump
far off one leg we also want to think
about speed drills things like marching
ease and high knees doing these and over
speed training all of that stuff is
gonna help us to run faster and thereby
produce more force into our jumps I did
make a whole video on that of course he
probably Noah's gonna say that so check
that out too if you want to learn more
about running faster finally if we want
to be able to jump over things and this
is really rather important
then we also need to think about
flexibility again this time we're
thinking about flexibility in terms of
bringing our legs up quickly in that
Apple mentioned wired video they found
that the Box jump was actually as much
about technique and flexibility as it
was jump height actually the height of
the hips doesn't change that much even
when you're jumping 4 to 2 inches and
above because you're bringing your legs
up high and using that to get onto the
legends we're trying to land on this
ability in itself will be more useful
for us when we're doing things like
kicking people in the face or doing cat
leaps the best way to train that would
be with dynamic stretches so high kick
straight forwards head height things
like that and in one of the upcoming
videos when I talk about the chordae
we're gonna talk about how you can bring
your legs up more quickly engaging your
core to do so the idea is to jump high
in the air then contort yourself in a
small little ball or whatever shapes
that you can move gracefully past that
obstacle so now we can practice this
today by using tuck jumps so as well as
those jump squats and jump up in the air
and tuck your legs as high as you can
likewise jumping kicks are great thing
to practice etc see our Nightwing leg
day needs to involve training with
squats
90 percent of our one minute max if
possible using other exercises that
target the posterior chain making sure
to engage the glutes using plyometric
exercises to engage force and launch
high up into the air using depth jumps
and shock training training our
explosive speed with Sprint's which will
also be fantastic for building fast
twitch muscle fibers in the calves etc
then we're going to Train flexibility
making sure to stretch the tibialis
anterior at the same time we're gonna
use dynamic stretching in order to be
able to get our legs up quickly in the
air so that we can fold up and move over
things I'm gonna train Sprint's because
they're really useful for jumping over
things far more practical than jumping
for me dead stop and we're gonna train
single leg strength so that means things
like pistol squats in these things
side squats etc if you want to see this
full routine broken down for you then
you can head over to the link in the
description visit the bow near comm I'll
share it there I'm gonna be sharing some
extra information over at the patreon
each of this videos will have a little
bit of supplementary information over
there just as a big thank you to all of
those of you who are supporting me there
they tuned of course if you want to see
the chordae it pull push day and the
proprioceptive flexibility day that will
sounds interesting and cool then
subscribe comment down below all that
stuff thanks so much for watching I
massively appreciate it and I'll see you
next time
bye for now Nathan my buddy has come to
help me offering me support and he will
definitely catch me if it goes wrong
saying there's no way this can possibly
end with me hurting myself and I feel
Hydra percent confident
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you